- Welcome back!
We've had fun this hour,
but before we go, I have
one last heartwarming story.
This is, What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
Tomorrow is election day, people,
and this next story is a reminder
the American dream is
still alive and well.
Estefania recorded her parents
dropping her off at work for
her first day as an attorney,
just like they did when she
was starting school as a kid.
What makes this extra special,
is that she's the first
person in her family
to graduate college and law school.
Let's get her in here.
Everybody say hi to Estefania.
Watching on NBC Chicago at 3:00.
(audience applause)
Hello!
- Hello.
Thank you so much for having me.
- No, thank you so much for being awesome!
We're so excited to highlight.
So your parents, they seemed so proud.
So tell us about them.
- Yes, so I grew up in Chicago.
My parents immigrated
here from Tarabu, Mexico
before I was born.
My parents have been
extremely present in my life.
They would take any time off of work
to be at every single one of my events.
Whether it was academic
or extra curriculars,
they were there.
Starting from a very young age,
they reinforced that education
was the route to success in this country.
I watched them sacrifice and work so hard
so that I could be successful.
- Aw, that's incredible.
Why do you think so many people
have responded the way
they have to this video?
- I think achieving a goal
with a foundation of hard work,
sacrifice and love for your people
really just resonated with everyone
and that's especially true
with the Latino community.
It's a reminder that the
American dream isn't dead.
There's an entire generation of immigrants
and children of immigrants like myself,
who are breaking barriers
and becoming widely successful
in their respective career paths,
and then on top of it,
Latinas in law is a huge focus of mine.
Latinos make up just 2%
of the legal profession,
but Latinos make up 19% of
our population at this point.
It's time that the percentage grew
to reflect our population
as a whole in this country.
- Absolutely!
Well, way to get the ball rollin', mam.
Congratulations.
We're all super proud of you.
Thanks Estefania.
I'm liking your post right now.
(audience applause)
And that's not all,
our season long partner
Pilot pen makers of Frixion,
the go to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show,
want to truly honor unstoppable
people just like you, mam,
so they're going to be writing
you a check for $1,000.
You deserve it.
- Thank you so much.
- No, absolutely.
You deserve it.
Congratulations,
and thank you to all our guests this hour.
Angela Bassett, Raymond
Lee, Lindsey Stirling,
and Chem Teacher Phil.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not great, try and change it.